so dallas mavericks owner mark cuban
says that they aren't going to play the
national anthem before mavericks games
now
sparking outrage amongst lots of people
in texas the nba
immediately responded and said that as
league rules require they have to play
the national anthem so
that more or less is not government
action now leagues occupy a weird
liminal space but arguably these
restrictions are probably fine but what
isn't fine is that texas introduced a
bill to
require all sports teams to play the
national anthem
this is clearly unconstitutional it's
compelled speech you can't do that under
the first amendment though there is a
wrinkle they're trying to tie this to
public funding now you can't just say
anyone that receives public funding
must play the national anthem but it is
possible that if you tied it to public
funding in the sense that if you take
this money
then you must play the national anthem
that might work
it's not clear if this law is going to
pass and it should worry anyone that
believes in free speech but what do i
know i'm just a lawyer so subscribe or
i'll see you
in court